resulta inédito que un grupo de más de
20 venezolanos migrantes que estaban
transitando y regularmente Guatemala
hayan renunciado a su empresa de llegar
a Estados Unidos por tierra y se hayan
embarcado en un avión de vuelta a su
natal Venezuela así lo confirmó el
Instituto guatemalteco de migración
quien los asistió Este martes para que
tomaran un avión desde el Aeropuerto
Internacional la Aurora en ciudad de
Guatemala hasta el aeropuerto
internacional de maiquetía Simón Bolívar
en la ciudad de Caracas lo particular de
esta decisión es que la hayan tomado
luego de haber atravesado el periplo más
dificultoso de esta ruta migratoria que
viene siendo el tapón del Darío en la
selva inhóspita entre Colombia y Panamá
donde muchos de ellos pierden la vida
pero también se entiende la decisión por
cuenta del anuncio de la semana pasada
de Estados Unidos de deportar expulsar a
todos aquellos venezolanos que
atraviesen la frontera sur de una manera
ilegal contraria a la suerte de estos
venezolanos más de 2.500 de ellos En lo
corrido octubre han sido capturados y
deportados expulsados del país por los
pasos fronterizos inmediatamente
anteriores de Guatemala que vienen
siendo los de Honduras entre tantos de
otros venezolanos que han sido repelidos
por los operativos policiales aguardan
por otros cientos de sus compatriotas
que vienen en camino por Centroamérica
para de manera conjunta embarcarse en
una caravana masiva y por lo menos
llegar a México